هي مجرد عين مدرب مرنة رائعة
بالنسبة لنا هنا في الإمارات
أه بعض الدعم الملحوظ
للجميع
نعم سيدي ،
آه
ما أردت أن أفعله هذا الصباح فقط
تعال وأقول شكرًا لك على
ما تفعله ،
أخبرك
أننا  نحن ممتنون جدًا لخدمتك التي
يفخر بها بلدك
بك وهذه منظمة فريدة من نوعها حيث
تعلم أننا نمتلك الكثير من القدرات هنا
أنواع مختلفة من القدرات
التي نجمعها معًا لتوفير
قدرة شاملة
كبيرة للقوة المشتركة.
إذا كنت
لا تتذكر أي شيء أقوله اليوم ،
فأنا أريدك أن تتذكر
شيئين ، أول شيء هو أن
وجودك هنا يحدث فرقًا لا يُصدق ،
كما تعلم ، لقد أمضيت أه
اليومين الماضيين في إشراك كبار القادة
أه في المنطقة هنا
لتذكيرهم بأن الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية
ملتزمة بشركائنا وحلفائنا
في
المنطقة وأنت تعلم أن لدينا وجودًا هنا
لدينا عشرات الآلاف من القوات التي
تعرفها في جميع أنحاء المنطقة.
تمطر بعد تعليق أه الطمع
والآن عاد لتوه مؤخرًا من
تلك الأمهات التي يعمل فيها على الألوية
وقمت بدمجهم في مدرسة كبيرة ،
إنه مثال رائع للبحارة الشباب الآخرين
أيضًا